marcó esta movilización un punto de
inflexión para la llegada del presidente
Gustavo Petro la presidencia y quizás de
Francia Márquez también
Buenas noches Andrés efectivamente el
estallido social presentó el 28
el pasado año 2021 fue digamos una de
las causas que propiciaron que por
primera vez muchos años Un gobierno de
izquierda pudiera llegar a gobernar en
Colombia no las grandes demandas e
insatisfacciones que tenía la sociedad
civil alrededor de puntos claves como el
tema económico sumado a venir de una
pandemia que desdibujó en gran medida
los derechos de la ciudadanía
propició que hubieran estas demandas por
parte de la población y que supo
encausar en alguna medida un sector
político de la izquierda y
específicamente Gustavo Petro ahora que
usted menciona estas demandas con la
llegada de Gustavo Petro siguen vigentes
Cómo se han abordado estas demandas de
los manifestantes
bueno recientemente algunas
organizaciones de la sociedad civil han
hecho un balance después de estos dos
años del estallido social y lo que uno
puede ver es una insatisfacción en estos
sectores puesto que algo que se
demandaba durante el gobierno de Iván
Duque era una reforma policial no una
reforma también al esmad durante estas
protestas quebraron casi alrededor de
cuatro meses hubo un total de 75 muertos
comprobados y
en 28 ocasiones hubo denuncias de
violencia sexual
sin embargo
esta reforma alrededor de la policía
Todavía no se ha dado y lo que se
evidencia es que tampoco hay una
participación de la sociedad civil
acerca de lo que está pasando ahora con
la reforma frente al esmad no
adicionalmente a Ello hay que recordar
que hoy satisfacción
referente a los temas laborales exigían
mejores condiciones laborales y sobre
todo también pensionales actualmente lo
que está haciendo el gobierno si bien es
encausar una agenda
relacionada con reformas pensionales
tributarias Y además que ponen en
evidencia también el factor laboral no
hay que olvidar que en la coyuntura
actual de lo que pasa en el legislativo
el gobierno está sufriendo algunos
reveses para tramitar estas agendas lo
cual ha conllevado también a que no se
puedan surtir estos cambios que demanda
la sociedad y que estuvieron presentes
en estas mesas de concertación durante
el paro nacional del 2021 en Valencia en
que van estas denuncias que en su
momento presentaron varias
organizaciones frente a los distintos
tipos de violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos que se dieron durante las
protestas
Bueno en lo que podemos ver Es que sobre
todo hay una gran impunidad
apenas en el 5% de los casos que se
denunciaron hay un componente de de
justicia de sanción y apenas un uno
punto cuatro por ciento en donde estas
denuncias apenas están en fase de
investigación
algunas organizaciones sociales han
documentado un total de
3.400 casos de violencia policial esto
es sumamente grave y
y al constatar que solo en promedio un
5% de estos casos están siendo
judicializados habla de una inoperancia
total de del estado y y de los y de los
actores judiciales
que uno uno de los espacios uno de los
territorios donde más afectaciones hubo
la Ciudad de Cali especialmente en el
barrio de siloé actualmente estas
comunidades están siendo revictimizadas
lo que podemos observar en el presente
año es que actores ilegales armados Como
por ejemplo el clan del Golfo están
incluso amenazando algunos
ciudadanos algunas poblaciones de estos
territorios que precisamente están
exigiendo que en el marco de las
denuncias y de la violación de derechos
que se surtieron alrededor de este paro
nacional se puedan redimir no entonces
lo que vemos es una revisión por parte
esos grupos armados